there are five things that you must know
about Epstein-Barr virus now why is it
so important to know more about this
virus well simply because the chances
are pretty great that you have this
virus and it could potentially create a
problem in your life and so the more you
know about it the less you are going to
be adversely affected by it roughly 95
of the population has this virus so
that's greater than 9 out of 10 people
so this virus definitely pertains to you
and having this information can greatly
protect you against a problem with this
virus so I've seen by a viruses called
the kissing virus because a lot of times
people get it when they're in their
teenage years but even children can get
it as well
but they are usually asymptomatic and
probably because Epstein-Barr virus
primarily attacks a certain immune cell
called the B cell b lymphocyte and
that's part of the acquired immune
system that develops as you get older
but that's just my theory it could be
another reason
but this information is based on this
new book that I'm reading called latency
strategies of herpes viruses okay
I show this to my wife and she's like
well I'll let you read it first she has
absolutely no interest in reading this
book but she appreciates me reading it
and summarizing it for her but this book
is all about the strategies that the
herpea viruses use to go underneath the
radar and survive and live in your body
and this term latency means
if the virus goes in a dormant state it
hides in your body and it's very
difficult for your immune system to
detect if not impossible so there are
certain viruses that when you get
infected they stay in your body and they
can potentially come out in certain
environments other viruses are killed
and they can be eliminated from the body
the latent viruses stay in your body so
number one we're going to get to five
things the Epstein-Barr virus is in the
family of the herpes virus and it's one
of the viruses that can go into this
latent phase so you get infected it
creates a lot of problems with your
throat glands it can create severe
fatigue and achiness of the joint and I
had it when I was I think in 10th Grade
and it was terrible I couldn't breathe
because my throat was so close down and
I just had to wait it out and kind of
get through it but it can be pretty
nasty and then after a period of time it
can fully kind of go away you know
usually it could take two three to four
weeks okay and then in your mind you
think okay that's gone I'll never get
that again right well here's the thing
about Epstein-Barr virus you can never
get rid of it you have to just focus on
keeping it in remission which has
everything to do about understanding the
sneaky little tricks and strategies that
this virus uses to survive and then what
you can do to help your own immune
system keep this thing at Bay once you
get this virus you cannot get it out of
the body well actually I lied there is
one way that you can get it out of the
body and I learned that in this book you
can get rid of all your bone marrow and
replace it or transplant it with a new
bone marrow from someone who does not
have this virus but that might be a
little impractical so the first thing to
know is that we can't get rid of it so
the goal should be to keep it
in remission what's so wild about
viruses especially this virus is the
sophistication of strategies that it has
developed
over a long period of time to stay alive
and do its damage when viruses really
are supposed to be not alive they're
just this genetic material wrapped in
the sack
but it's very very mysterious on how
they can be dead but live off yourselves
and develop all these wild strategies
which I'll get into a few the second
thing you need to know is the
Epstein-Barr virus is associated with
the increased risk of certain cancers
autoimmune diseases rheumatoid arthritis
is associated with Epstein-Barr virus
chronic fatigue syndrome as well as
fibromyalgia so when the virus gets
reactivated it doesn't necessarily
exhibit all the full-blown symptoms that
maybe you had when you first got it it
may manifest in fatigue soreness
lethargy brain fog achy joints and achy
muscles maybe a headache maybe your
glands are a little bit swollen and
number three and this is very
interesting
this sneaky virus
blocks through various mechanisms
the key immune nutrients that your cells
depend on to keep them functioning
correctly okay the first vitamin that
we'll go after is vitamin D I mean it
has the ability to take your receptors
for vitamin D and downgrade them so it
would be like sticking an ear plug in
your ear so you can't hear as much so it
affects the receiving end of vitamin D
because somehow this virus knows that
vitamin D
keeps your immune system strong and it's
intimately involved with every part of
your immune system so if it can block
that it has an advantage okay so it
downgrades the receptor of Vitamin D it
binds to the receptor
okay so it binds with it blocks that it
also interferes with the metabolism of
vitamin D
so now you can't
go from the inactive to the active
vitamin D and it affects the absorption
of vitamin D in your gut now the second
nutrient that it interferes with is zinc
it interferes with the zinc Transporters
not allowing zinc to be transported to
the different parts of the immune system
so if your immune system is deficient in
zinc it can't release the weapons that
the immune system needs to destroy
viruses there's a lot of research of
using the active form of vitamin A
retinol to inhibit the Epstein-Barr
virus so it blocks the absorption of
vitamin A and this is really important
to know because vitamin A is essential
in mucous membranes and producing the
mucous barrier to prevent this virus
from invading the tissues and so this is
just another reason why making sure you
have enough vitamin A
vitamin D in zinc in your diet is so
important and on top of that
remember when I mentioned that the
Epstein-Barr virus has a primary
mechanism of attacking
the B lymphocytes okay well it just so
happens that the primary nutrient that
the B lymphocytes need is vitamin A
retinol all right so now that you have
that there's another thing that
Epstein-Barr virus does to survive
it has the ability to bypass your immune
system's regulation of temperature
during a viral attack so basically it
can prevent you from getting a fever so
you might think that's a good thing but
you have to realize that your immune
system heats up to actually inactivate
viruses so here you are you have this
reactivation of this this virus and
you're tired you're brain fog but maybe
you don't have a fever to help you get
rid of it so it just lingers on for week
after week month after month this is
kind of important information because if
you start to feel maybe some of the
symptoms or subclinical symptoms of an
Epstein-Barr Virus Infection you should
be going into the sauna you should be
taking a hot bath you should be trying
to induce some type of a fever in your
body by maybe wearing a lot of clothes
while you're in bed to stay really hot
and stay out of the cold temperature
that may help help you the fifth thing
that you need to know emotional stress
and more specifically things related to
loss of a loved one loss of money loss
of anything or any emotional stress
in practice I've noticed
nearly a hundred percent of the time
people that had autoimmune diseases
people that that were had chronic
fatigue syndrome and fibromyalgia always
had emotional stress think about what
stress does stress activates cortisol
what does Cortisol do it suppresses the
immune system
it opens up a door for these viruses to
come out and create a lot of problems
the importance of this or the
significance of this is for you to start
to really focus more on dealing with the
stress than any other Factor since if
you can resolve the stress somehow you
can actually put this thing back in
remission there's other things that can
also activate this virus out of
remission certain toxins pollution
chemicals drugs the contraceptive pill
yeah that can increase your risk of
having it come out of remission other
infections like the cold like flu
covid even certain vaccines like the
covet vaccine can bring this thing out
because of what it does to the immune
system and also steroids like prednisone
or certain medications that are
steroid-based can actually activate this
virus why because a steroid is cortisol
and cortisol suppresses the immune
system so yes it gets rid of the
inflammation it makes you feel better
temporarily
when a little bit later all of a sudden
now you end up with more outbreaks all
right the plan number one is concentrate
more on this very very important factor
of stress do whatever you can to resolve
the stress chronic stress especially if
you're kind of stuck between Rock and
Hard Place with whatever that can be
probably the most important thing to do
to keep this thing in remission and of
course if there's any other triggers
like you're taking birth control pills
and you notice that this virus comes out
every time you take a pill then you're
going to have to come up with a plan B
all right number two make sure you're
getting enough vitamin D zinc and
retinol it just so happens that there is
one thing that has a really nice balance
of vitamin d and vitamin A and that is
cod liver oil and there are some natural
herbs that can help suppress viruses
especially the Epstein-Barr virus I put
some research down below specifically on
these herbs that I'm going to tension
I'm not recommending getting all of them
but one or two would be a smart thing so
we have Elderberry we have Echinacea we
have olive leaf extract and then we have
andrographis which is an herb that has
significant effects over that
Epstein-Barr virus and then we have
astragalus which is a Chinese herb to
help put this Epstein-Barr virus back
into remission I've done a lot of videos
on how to reduce stress since that's the
most important thing related to this
topic
I highly recommend you watch this video
that I put out on what to do if you
experience chronic stress check it out